it's an iconic item absolutely cool all
right thanks jc time to get cooking
in nanny bubby's kitchen today she's
getting us ready for march
madness with a retro pasta salad hey
nanny bubby
well hey there rocky happy st patrick's
day to you guys these are my st
patrick's day tools but we're not
talking about a st
patrick's day recipe today we are
talking about a retro
pasta salad from the late 70s and
i remember sitting around watching the
um final four and march madness with my
family
and watching the running rebels for the
very first time
make it to the final four led by none
other than the amazing reggie theis
and so i'm sure that is a great memory
for you and your family
and it is a wonderful memory that your
father brought to this community
so so happy to be walking down that
memory lane so this
is how we start we start with a pound
of rotini pasta so we're going to put it
in sometimes it's called facili it just
depends on what brand
and i just want to remind you how to cut
a pepper
ready you're just so easy down the sides
just like this there we go
there you go and we're just going to
drop the core right into our chapman
kitchen garbage can
and i took the liberty of chopping it
before we hit the air so
there we go there's orange i'm using
orange because it adds fabulous color
then we're going to add some english
cucumbers
the thing about these english cucumbers
is that you want to
slice them in half lengthwise and then
what you want to do with a grapefruit
spoon
is get rid of the seeds right into your
chapman garbage can right there
there you go and you can see how lovely
they're cut in just little half inch
pieces
and that goes right in so let's just
give it a toss
so we can get these colors melding
together how do you like that
okay next we're going to add some green
onions
now i like to use the green onions
instead of a red onion or a white onion
use whatever you like but raw onions and
i don't get along so i prefer
the scallions because they're much
lighter
and not so acidy to my stomach so that's
what i use
so we're going to throw those in okay
next we are gonna do our great tomato
slicer
so this is my very favorite handy dandy
kitchen tool
i hope you're liking this rocky there we
go
there we go with those tomatoes and then
we're going to load this right back up
one two three
just push them down and i just want to
tell you that the grapefruit spoon
and the tomato slicer and the
salad supreme seasoning and the salad
dressing you can find on nannybubby.com
game changers okay there we go right
into the bowl look at can you see how
these colors are really starting to meld
together
i think we could use just a little bit
more okay there we go
okay into the bowl let's give it one
more toss
now these have tremendous color but i
just want to just share
because of saint patrick's day if you
want to make this all
green then substitute the orange pepper
for a green one
separate the onion with a jalapeno and
then the tomatoes
use these cute little green tomatillos
that are
covered you have to peel them and that
will make an
all green salad for you now what we want
to do is we want to cut the basil let me
just push that off while we get to the
basil now remember how i do this
is we take the large leaves and we wrap
them around the smaller leaves so let me
just
take this and roll this right up like a
cigar
makes it very easy just to chop the
basil
there we go there we go
into the bowl so that adds some
delicious flavor
half cup of parmesan cheese oh my gosh
are you loving this so far and now don't
tell anybody we're using jarred
seasoning
and jarred salad dressing because after
all this is from the 80s
and the late 70s which is what people
did and i did in those years
and we are going to take the salad
supreme that is still on the market
today
and we are using the entire jar yep
you heard me right the entire jar look
at that
all the way right on top we're going to
give this a toss and coat
all of the pasta with the salad oh my
gosh look at this and it smells
wonderful i wish you were here
and then the salad dressing and then
parsley on top
so that's it we're running just slightly
out of time
but you're going to do that and finish
with some
parmesan shavings so look at that just
right off the top
and there you go a retro march
madness salad okay there you go
that's it for today have a wonderful
weekend with march madness love you to
death remember to spread love like
butter
we love you too nanny bubby oh that was
great and my mom and dad are watching
and they just text me so that was so
cool so thank you so much
check out annie bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment
we'll be right back